>> I began with the real part
of my professional career
in a school that was
broken in about as many ways
as a school can be, and knew
this has to be done better.
My name is Jason Singer
and I'm the principal
of Kipp King Collegiate
High School.
What really galvanized for
me when I started thinking
about Kipp as a solution was
that your zip code did not
confer upon you a limited amount
of opportunity, as
opposed to a limitless one.
We've told our kids since
fifth grade that the focus
of your work is to
get to college.
And our theory of
practice at King is
that critical thinking
wins the day.
>> My name is Jared Kushida.
I teach history at Kipp
King Collegiate High School
in San Lorenzo, California.
If there's a constant theme
throughout my teaching,
it's that I wanna have
Socratic dialog, you know,
critical thinking
skills almost every day.
>> The hallmark of it is
questions, thought provoking,
difficult questions
being asked by a teacher,
and thought provoking
and difficult questions
being asked by students.
>> If you were like, 'Hey,
Kushida, what can I--
how much does an A
cost in this class?'
and you took out your wallet
and, you know, I was like,
'I think 50 bucks would work,
which one of us would
be corrupt in that case?
>> The trust that Kushida gives
them is what empowers them.
>> It would be you.
Because you're the one
that's asking for it, right?
So whoever is asking
for an illegal
or immoral favor is corrupt?
>> You're the one that's
asking for the money.
>> But what's the
relationship between us?
What's the power relationship?
I'm higher power, so could you
be corrupt in that relationship,
or would it have to be me?
>> It really had to grow on
me, because in ninth grade,
I was not a good student.
But then, meeting the teachers,
and their passion
really just made me want
to stay and want to learn.
To me, critical thinking means
thinking beyond what you hear.
It makes me think about
myself differently.
education differently.
It's more than just
about academics.
It's about, you know, what
you know in your brain,
in your heart, in your soul.
>> My name is Kate Belden.
Currently, I'm the
assistant principal
of Kipp King Collegiate
High School.
I teach Leadership One
and Leadership Two.
We're on a team where everyone
is devoted to our mission,
that it is possible for
every single student
that attends our school to
have the opportunity to go
to four year college if
they want to do that.
>> When they walk on a college
campus for their first time,
you know, they're gonna
be hit almost immediately
with so many crises
of confidence.
They're going to be surrounded
by predominantly white students,
when their entire
education here,
they've been surrounded
predominantly
by people of color.
>> We can't control the
fact that they're gonna be
in a situation for
the first time,
at least in the last
eight years, where they're
with a lot of affluent students.
We can't control those
things, so we think about,
how can we best prepare them to
be extraordinarily comfortable
in the academic setting?
>> When that professor
starts speaking,
if their legs kinda steel
beneath them, and they're able
to say to themselves, 'I got
this,' then at that point,
it's beyond just having power.
What we want them to
have is influence.
>> What does control mean to you
and what does influence
mean to you?
>> For control, it's
kinda like yourself,
and then for influence, is
that a lotta people
can influence you,
so it's individual
and then more people.
>> The people we
are controlling,
they don't really have an option
to do something else
besides what you say,
whereas influence is more like,
you're giving them an option,
or like persuading them
to do a certain thing.
>> I feel that in order to
gain control, you must have
like influence as a catalyst,
and to gain influence,
you should have control.
>> We have no idea whether
students at King are persisting
in college, because we're
graduating our first class now.
I mean, time will tell.
Persistence rates
will either prove
or disprove this notion we have
of the importance of
critical thinking.
But when I look at our seniors,
there is a difference
in disposition.
They have a presence that
really gives me confidence
that they're ready to succeed.